thank you so much now if you're ready to
get in shape but want to skip the
crowded gym and get some extra
personalized attention there's a new
facility in town waiting just for you so
let's head to alloy personal training
the sponsors of this segment
[Music]
hey Anna hi welcome to alloy thank you I
love it in here now this is your first
location here in Vegas introduce us to
the alloy way yes alloy is personal
training in a small group setting and
you know we love small group because it
provides community and accountability
love that now first time client what
happens first we'll take you through our
starting point session so what's step
one I'd interview you so tell me what's
your Fitness history
um college basketball okay now I do
Pilates and spin okay nice and what's
step two now I take you to our inbody
where it reads your body composition I'm
scared let's go
okay so this is not your typical scale
it not only reads your total body weight
but it'll also read your skeletal muscle
mass as well as your body fat percentage
it will also read how hydrated you are
all this information helps me create a
program for our clients now what's step
three our movement assessment do you
have any injuries from basketball oh
tendonitis in my knees okay well let's
see if you can do this okay
let's just bring it all the way above
your head okay okay now from here go
ahead and get into a squat okay
okay are you feeling any pain that's
about as far as I can go okay come on up
and let's go ahead and slide just your
heels onto the board okay
okay like this okay now keeping the
dowel above your head go ahead and get
into that squat
[Music]
very nice okay come on up I just want to
remind you that there's no right or
wrong and there's no passing and failing
with this it just allows me to see how
you're currently moving okay Anna what
did you notice about my movement uh you
had a little bit of you had some limited
Mobility yes now is that why raising my
ankles helped me get lower yes so that's
why when you repeated the movement with
your heels up it allowed you to get into
a deeper squat this is what actually
makes this different from all the other
studios around town it's because we
actually put you through a movement
assessment to find your starting point
and then from there we work you toward
your goals now I just have tendonitis
but this is really good for people with
actual injuries too right absolutely
this allows me to see how they're
currently moving and it'll help me get
them to their golden moving pain-free
and that's actually really good for the
older population right because they
probably have injuries and limited
Mobility as well absolutely and this
allows me to help them regain their
mobility and their strength okay Rocky
so with all the information I gathered
for me today this will help me prescribe
the right exercises for you when you
come back in for your workout and I'm
really excited about this information
this is how I'll track my progress right
exactly okay so once a month we'd get
you on our in body machine again and
right here as you can see it'll record
all your progress that's the okay that's
why we're stronger together absolutely
and that's what alloy means it is about
combining two or more solid elements to
give greater strength
thank you alloy personal training for
sponsoring that segment giving me a
little workout give them a call at
702-829-5006 or visit
alloypersonaltraining.com for more
information they do have a special offer
for the community they are new in town
they're giving you 50 off first month of
training session so take advantage of
that and we'll be right back right here
in Las Vegas now